hi everyone my name is Claire Evans I'm
Jonah Bechtel and together we co-author
an entity called yacht
based in Los Angeles California yacht is
a band that's what we're known for and
that's why we're here but we see being a
public entity as an opportunity to
create weird and interesting on and off
screen experiences for many different
people in many different mediums and on
many different scales
here's a quick collage of some of the
things that we've made these objects
ranged from traditional band souvenirs
like cassette tapes merchandise pins
kiss cat sticker sheets an iPhone case
to more esoteric projects like a line of
sunglasses but actually they came out
today
which is awesome for us a laptop sleeve
which was designed to look like a manila
envelope which we created when the
original MacBook Air was unveiled in
2008 when Steve Jobs pulled out of a
manila envelope of course or finally a
free iPhone app called five everyday
which gives us users five interesting
things to do in the city of Los Angeles
every day that we select and write about
as a band however um we've been
releasing albums singles and
compilations on CD cassette vinyl and
digital formats since 2002 on literally
every scale yeah from self-made CD ours
printed right so graph style on just
paper two albums with elaborate global
packaging and global reach we really
love to experiment with format and
distribution for example last year we
recorded a song called party at the NSA
which was a protest song against the
unwarranted government surveillance of
private citizens but we know that in the
21st century a protest song can't really
just be music so we designed a party at
the NSA fundraising campaign selling the
song online in exchange for donations
the Electronic Frontier Foundation who
as you may know litigate on behalf of
public interest against the US
government and the corporations that
collude with it to invade the privacy of
innocent citizens after we were invited
to perform party at the NSA on the
Capitol steps during stop watching us
the largest anti-surveillance rally
today this project evolved from just
being a digital experiment to a very
real-world protest
the way that we see it it's one thing to
create text design and music that
engages people online but it's a lot
more fun to bring those experiences into
the world as musicians our bread and
butter is live performance so forging
offline connections with people in the
real world is really important to us as
you may know in the creative field one
of the questions you get in the
interviews and just from people is what
is your inspiration which when it's
directed towards musician we think means
something more like where does a song
begin like what is the seed of a song
and it can seem kind of miraculous when
you listen to music to imagine that a
song could emerge from nothing but it
doesn't of course like any form of art a
song is like a snowball it doesn't
emerge into the world fully formed it
begins as something small even
inconsequential the real work is in
rolling that tiny pebble down the hill
through the world gathering weight and
substance as you go along in our minds
this is a process I can go on forever
forever and it's really about finding a
right place to stop let us give you an
example so in August of last year we
started making a new song and I started
with just a bass line
throughout history a cool baseline has
really been the foundation of a good
song we think for us at least we want to
talk to you about the process so that
transforms something as simple as a bass
line into a song and then to something
much bigger than a song but let's go
back to the bass line we sat with it for
a while but we knew that we needed a
hook so I rifled through my notebooks
and I found a line that I'd literally
scribbled in the margins where does this
disk go it was actually a lyric that I
misheard in a different thought song but
we thought it was funny and humor is
important so we laid down a scratch
vocal it clicked immediately into that
bass line and as we loop this hook and
listen to it over and over again in our
studio it began to evoke a very specific
interest for us the decaying role of
physical media in the buying and selling
of music we began to think about those
boxes and boxes of CDs and vinyl LPs
that hitch a ride with us around the
world on tour when the compact disc was
first commercially introduced in the
early 80s it was marketed as a more
durable more portable and higher
fidelity alternative to the vinyl record
advertisements produced by Sony and
Philips who created the technology in
tandem extolled the virtue of the laser
playhead which wouldn't damage the CD
the way that a needle wears into the
grooves of a record it was even called
unbreakable yeah and one of the original
marketing tag lines was pure perfect
sound forever the CD is inherently
futuristic or future-proof as we were
told but of course as we all know that's
not true
for one technology eventually outpaced
the allegedly perfect fidelity of the CD
format and compact discs themselves are
very delicate objects easily marred by
scratches and smudges a little over 30
years after it was released the compact
disc now exists in a very strange and
precarious position it remains the most
commercial medium for the buying and
selling
music in Japan 85% of music is still
purchased on compact discs and yet
despite that ubiquity it feels obsolete
there's really no cultural cachet for CD
collectors of course this is a
subjective assessment but it feels
really true to our experience as we
design and sell plenty of CDs of our own
music but it's probably been 10 years
since I bought a CD we very rarely buy
them for ourselves like a lot of
consumers we've switched to streaming
services which are devaluing music to
its lowest point in history instead of
$10 for a piece of plastic containing a
dozen songs we now pay $10 a month for
access to nearly every song ever
recorded the advantage is so great that
it has converted us whose work it may or
may not devalue which doesn't really
bode well for the compact discs for a
lot of people a CD is no longer an
object of value in of itself it's more
like a place where digital music is
temporarily imprisoned once the songs
are freed and encoded to the cloud the
CD itself becomes nothing more than an
empty vessel no better than a coaster
all of this is to say we started writing
a song about compact discs not not
literally about compact discs but using
that metaphor of the simultaneous
ubiquity and obsolescence of the compact
discs and physical media itself to talk
about something else that took the line
between existence and non-existence love
and so with those parameters in place
the rest of the lyrics came really
easily we thought about loops erasure
spinning and reflections but before we
were anywhere near finishing the song we
began designing the physical release and
its accompanying materials we often
consider how a song will look before
we're even done settled on how it sounds
the process of design and Composition
inform one another making a CD about CDs
in a landscape where CDs are growing
obsolete was a really interesting design
challenge for us the logo was easy
obviously since the title of a song is a
pun we thought a visual pen would be
cheap but appropriate but what about the
thing itself how do we turn this mundane
object into a desirable even beautiful
thing
selling physical copies of music is not
an impossible pursuit as you may know
there's been a huge resurgence in the
popularity of vinyl in an age of
intangible media people really respond
to the tactility of records we sell far
more vital than seize at our shows and
that even more maligned medium the
cassette tape has actually hit a nerve
with a lot of DIY artists and labels
looking to find cheap ways to copy and
distribute music as of 2012 the indie
cassette label Berger records had sold a
hundred thousand tapes
perhaps the CD could experience a
similar revival in coming generations
becoming a fetish object for people far
enough removed from the technologies
initial dominance to find it retro or
kitsch so who would this in mind when we
set out to design the physical packaging
for where does this disco we started by
searching for rare and interesting
varieties of compact discs in the wild
what's known as a minimax fan disc or
clear edge disc caught our eyes it's a
three inch disc suspended at a normal
size clear platter you slot in
promotional materials in the 90s we saw
these discs as a perfect opportunity for
another visual joke so we designed the
CD to look like a tiny vinyl LP being
pulled out of a white label sleeve the
kind of sleeve popularized by dance
music and now more infamously by the
digital artwork for the new u2 album
who do you seem to want we got really
really into the details so this tiny
strip on the inner ring of a CD is
called a mirror band and it's usually
etched with the name of the manufacturer
and serial numbers or barcodes
associated with a product but we saw it
as another fragment of compact disc
Arcana and the ideal spot to hide a
secret message is dead long live the
compact disc we worked really closely
with the manufacturer during this
process and we learned a lot we've
really discovered that we didn't know
very much at all about how CDs are made
as it turns out like most things if you
scrutinize it enough this seemingly
mundane object comes from a really
beautiful and interesting process so
every mass-produced CD begins with
something called a glass master a round
plate of glass containing the discs
master data a glass master is only used
in the manufacturing process and is
usually destroyed or stored after the
CDs are printed
but we thought it was such an
interesting object that we convinced the
manufacturer to make us an extra glass
master it's really nice of them to have
that this is the where does this disco
glass master it's a process object if
you will
brought out from the shadows we also
learned that the foil coating on the
back of a CD doesn't store any data it's
actually just there to reflect the light
back to the laser playhead allowing the
data to be read on the disk the music is
in the plastic and so we entreated that
sweet long-suffering manufacturing plant
to create a run of CDs without their
mirrored foil a clear unplayable disc
containing the entirety of our musical
catalogue in a sense this useless object
allows the CD to retain a kind of
integrity there's no way to listen to
the songs edged onto it but there's also
no way that we know of to release those
digital files from their prison we
really hope that fans go to the effort
of proving it's wrong and some have said
they will yeah then we descended into a
vortex of seedy obsessions so we
commissioned the building of 2 4-foot
cds from acrylic and iridescent foil to
use as stage props from our tour or it's
kind of our take on disco balls
we designed tour t-shirts with
iridescent foil discs and we built a
website a single-serving website for the
tour
DRL is naturally where does this disco
dot today the biggest challenge of this
project has been designing an experience
that suggests that a CD might still be a
desirable object even an art object but
part of what determines a piece of Arts
value is its limited accessibility what
the cultural critic Walter benjamine
called its aura it's very specific
location in space and time but CDs are
by definition mass-produce objects every
CD is a mechanical reproduction of the
original recording that said there are
still ways to make these reproductions
feel like they have an aura of
specialness by orchestrating an
experience surrounding their consumption
so on this tour that we've been on at
the merch table we make fans believe
that this where doesn't this disco CD
package which we produced in an edition
of 500 is the only medium by which the
songs can be experienced of course it's
ultimately a losing battle
we know that fans will eventually rip
these songs off the discs and play them
on
most accessible devices but the game is
in the experience so we created a run of
carbonless copy NDA's which demand that
merge buying concert attendees promise
under penalty of law to keep a secret
before they can purchase the CD itself
the effect is completed by signs pasted
all around the venue which home
express that a secret is being
disseminated on the premises and that
attendees presence finds them legally in
the keeping of this secret a dummy a
CCTV camera and signs add to the mood
this is actually from the merchant Abel
in New York yeah you can buy these on
Amazon they're like 20 bucks
amazing admittedly this is an extreme
and largely symbolic way of countering
the growing obsolescence of physical
media in our industry but the question
which became interesting to us over the
course of this project was could we use
a song and its accompanying multimedia
treatment to suggest pre-emptive
nostalgia for the compact disc and by
suggesting that nostalgia can we modify
people's perceptions of where these
objects and their makers exist on the
continuum of technological history the
thing is that we have a lot in common
with compact discs where does music live
does it live in an encoded file of a
song or does it live in those
performances of those songs in a live
setting or somewhere in between and some
kind of abstract ineffable space where
the idea of music exists in any of these
cases we're just a couple of physical
containers that sort of transmit ideas
from creator to consumer from cloud to
cloud as artists and as people were no
more future proof than a foil plated
compact disc
we're hyper aware of this which is why
this baroque journey into the medium of
a CD has been so fascinating for us it's
been a way for us to explore our own
limitations to punch against the entropy
of our work and to have some fun in the
process we've made a point in the twelve
years of this band that's existed to
perpetually extend the boundaries of
what we do with design experiments like
this one yacht is not just music it's
text design video and above all ideas
this keeps us from becoming bored for
most and from settling into predictable
patterns of creativity
it's what keeps you alive so to return
to that original question where does the
song begin thank you mm-hmm
as it turns out that's not the
interesting question to us it's rather
where the song ends that's interesting
as a piece of information music is
finite
there are opening notes and final notes
there is a file size but if a song can
speak to a moment in time to a sub
cultural trend to a shared or
manufactured nostalgia then its
boundaries can be expanded dramatically
it can grow beyond a temporal existence
and beyond a crummy plastic jewel case
so where does it end if you think of a
song as something more than music if you
think of a song as a point of departure
for a process of design that it never
has to end at all
thank you